doc werden präsentiert von honda jazz
[Musik]
wir waren nicht landesverräter und was
die da gemacht haben und mit mit
lautlosen maschinenpistolen im wald
herum gekrochen
eigentlich es wurde als eine geheimloge
präsentiert die in der lage sei mit
waffen in der hand die regierung zu
stürzen
total dohmen und falsch würden wir alle
die dabei waren wir haben ihn überzeugt
gewesen von der richtigkeit dass man in
friedenszeiten etwas machen muss wenn
der notfall ist eine verlorene zeit
wieder im kalten krieg damals und da
sagte ich mir eben wenn ich etwas
beitragen kann dann mache ich es oder
ich hatte keine zweifel je in dieser
organisation mit
am ende des kalten krieges entdeckte die
schwarz die existenz einer geheimen
armee eine bedrohung für die demokratie
ein rechtes netzwerk putschisten lange
haben diese männer und frauen
geschwiegen
heute treten sie aus dem schatten
als ich eben als soldat meinen
militärdienst in der festung gemacht
habe und das war 19 54 58 als in einer
zeit als der kalte krieg auf großen
wirken große intensität tobte da wurden
wir verpflichtet eingebläut wurde uns
über die festungs angelegenheiten im zug
kein wort zu reden dass der staat
überhaupt niemand wissen dass dort
niemand wissen wo die festung nicht wie
die aussehen und wie blusen und und und
der zweite weltkrieg ist gerade zu ende
und schon teilt sich die welt in zwei
blöcke die vereinigten staaten und die
sowjetunion stehen sich gegenüber
der kalte krieg beginnt
dies löst ein beängstigendes nukleares
wettrüsten aus gleichgewicht des terrors
genannt
der kalte krieg er umfasst eine reihe
offener oder unterschwellige konflikte
auf der ganzen welt in ungarn
auf kuba in vietnam
in afghanistan
im jahr 1961 teilt der bau der berliner
mauer die welt in zwei teile für lange
zeit
[Musik]
die schweiz verbarrikadiert sich man
fürchtet die sowjetische invasion
daher macht der tschechei war
militärdienst 9 und bands dazu gemüse
und mir wurde am morgen mitgeteilt wie
gesagt die 500 bahn zu haben prag sind
in paraguay marschiert und wir alle
hatten wir auf dass die bands erfahrung
das bremspedal finden vor sie haben der
schweizer grenze stehen relativ am
bodensee kann mich sehr gut drinnen 1968
als wir am morgen zu arbeiten die ganze
es ist die russen haben die
tschechoslowakei besetzt
so erleben ist die tief gingen
es waren 3 400 kilometer von der
schweizer grenze weg sind die russen
gestanden mit dem panzern und innerhalb
von einem halben tag bei einem tag
während die hätten die die schweiz über
rollen können also bewaffnet man sich
die milizarmee zählt von jetzt an rund
700.000 man ein rekord
die armee trainiert mit allen
verfügbaren mitteln
niemand denkt daran dem nationalen
verteidigungsbudget schranken zu setzen
[Musik]
sogar eine atombombe ist ein szenario
und schon in den 50er jahren beschließt
die armee eine geheime
widerstandsorganisation zu gründen in
erwartung einer sowjetischen invasion
also man hat ja auch personen aus
holland im holländischen widerstand
waren haben in die schweiz eingeladen
und die haben dann über ihre erfahrungen
erzählt und hat festgestellt die
erfahrungen in holland passen besser auf
die schweiz
das gilt darum kontakt unter der
zivilbevölkerung kontakt zwischen den
besetzten gebieten und einer
exilregierung oder auch moralischer
widerstand das heißt die leute müssen
weiterhin schweizer sein müssen nein
sagen wir sind eigentlich demokratisch
auch wenn jetzt ein totalitäres regime
unsere setzt der kosten rechnete damit
der westen wolle angreifen der westen
rechnen mit der osten wollen angreifen
der kalte krieg war ein ganz wichtiger
rahmen der bildet den rahmen für diese
vorbereitungen
die nato länder reagieren in den
fünfziger und sechziger jahren identisch
überall werden geheime
widerstandsgruppen gebildet genannt
[Musik]
die stay behind organisation besteht aus
menschen die buchstäblich zurückbleiben
das bedeutet dass sich bei einer
invasion soldaten verstecken die
eindringlinge durch lassen und danach
die invasoren von hinten bekämpfen
das konzept wurde 1940 von den briten
eingeführt als sich deutschland auf den
angriff auf großbritannien vorbereitet
in der schweiz werden mehrere versuche
gemacht der so genannte special service
unter der leitung von oberst bachmann
scheitert kläglich
sein agent wird verhaftet als er manöver
der österreichischen armee ausspionieren
will special service wird eine affäre
bachmann
[Musik]
der skandal von 1979 veranlasst die
armee eine andere lösung zu suchen
es wird die p-26 sein oder projekt 26
angeführt von einem mann namens efrem
cattelan alias rico was wir können ganz
klar feststellen dass mit dem projekt 26
mit dem antritt von herrn pater 1979 die
vorbereitungen viel strukturierter
angegangen wurden es wurde auch klar
geführt sowohl der götter lang hat seine
leute geführt als auch heran wurde
geführt
das ist auch wichtig in der in den 70er
jahren arbeit braucht man hatte eine
sehr große freiheit braucht auch eine zu
große freiheit für seinen
aufgabenbereich die p 26 ist nach dem
vorbild des baby hand organisiert nach
strengen regeln der geheimhaltung und
aufsplitterung in separate gruppen
landesweit entstehen 40 regionen die
jeweils von einem schiff geleitet werden
die regionen in rot auf der karte gelten
als strategisch wichtiger als die in
blau
das grundprinzip jede region ist doppelt
vorhanden hätte in excel art idee rico
es war eine großartige idee von ricoh
aktive es gab eine aktive region eine
regional und eine sogenannte ruhende b
region
das heißt wenn im krieg eine region
zerstört worden wäre
gab es sofort die region b die
unverzüglich die funktion übernehmen
konnte das ist ein prinzip das nicht
rico erfunden hatte er sagte immer
seilrutschen der vietcong der diese idee
hatte es funktioniert wie bei der hydro
wenn du einen kopf abschlägt wächst
sofort ein anderer noch
ein paar kilometer von der stadt
burgdorf entfernt ein abgelegener
bauernhof heute stillgelegt für die p 26
ein ganz wichtiges gebäude einer der
chefs der organisation gibt auskunft
allerdings nur anonym
er spricht zum ersten mal vor der kamera
sein code name ich war sehr nah dran an
ich war einer der engsten mitarbeiter
von herrn kasse
und natürlich ging so ziemlich alles
durch martin rekrutierung ausbildungs
kontrolle etc dann auch die leitung die
verbindungen zu den regionen
wir hatten so genannte verarbeiten der
offiziere die near zugeteilt waren um
aufträge zu empfangen die sie in die
regionen übermittelt
es war eine relativ zentrale funktion in
der leitung des projekts
eine der ersten maßnahmen war einen
diskreten außenstandort zu finden wo er
catalan und andere sich treffen können
ohne eine identitätskontrolle und wir
fanden dieses gebäude in burgdorf dass
der armee gewährte ein restauriert das
bauernhaus ein sehr diskretes gebäude
das war 1983 oder 82
wer mitglied der p-26 werden wollte
musste bestimmte voraussetzungen
erfüllen
die männer und frauen erklärten sich
bereit im falle einer invasion ihr leben
zu riskieren
sie mussten lernen im geheimen zu
operieren
die rekrutierung erfolgte deshalb
diskret
[Musik]
bei der rekrutierung der p-26 geht es
überhaupt nicht um die idee bekannte
gesichter zu kontaktieren was für die
logik dahinter war bekannte menschen
sind die ersten die von den invasoren
verhaftet werden
ich glaube die geschichte zeigt recht
gut dass man zuerst die intellektuellen
verhaftet und dann entscheidet wer von
ihnen erschossen und wer in die lager
geschickt wird
deshalb könnten nur sehr wenige leute in
der öffentlichkeit die namen ein guter
freund von der familie hat mit dem hab
ich in der geschäftlich zu tun gehabt im
gewerbeverband und er hat mich wirklich
als von kleinauf gekannt hat die familie
gekannt und hab mich persönlich auch
kennengelernt in der arbeit und da hat
er mir eines tages gesagt ich möchte
dich mal persönlich sprechen und ich
konnte mir nicht vorstellen was er ist
etwa halt dieser tage hat er den 95
geburtstag gefeiert
also man sieht das sind 20 jahre
differenz und ich habe dann war ich
etwas erstaunt ja das war irgendwann in
den frühen 80er jahren 1980 er jahren da
kann ein bruder zu mir ein logen bruder
ich bin ja ein freimaurer bund und der
losen bruder wollte mit mir sprechen und
sagte ich soll doch eines tages zu ihm
ins büro kommen so war architekt im chor
und dann hat er gesagt es geht um mit
das ganz seriös und es ist für
die bevölkerung der schweiz zum schutz
und ich möchte dich einfach fragen ob
sie gewillt wäre es da mal etwas zu
erfahren und dass man dass du auch
bereit wäre es damit zu helfen
es ist eigentlich eine widerstands
organisation und ich habe mir dann
einige tage bedenkfrist ausbedungen habe
eine nacht darüber geschlafen habe ich
meine frau eben zu rudimentär erzählt
und habe dann erwogen und gesagt doch da
mache ich mit das eine gute sache
das interessiert mich dieser erste
kontakt genügt nicht die identität des
kandidaten wird von der bundespolizei
und der kantonalen polizei überprüft der
polizei ebene ging es nur darum ob die
person als problematisch bekannt war
oder große alkoholprobleme hatte für uns
war es entscheidend dass wir niemanden
rekrutierten mortier große probleme
verursachen oder der organisation
schaden konnte
dann entscheiden die
sicherheitsverantwortlichen über den
neuen rekruten wenn das licht grün ist
wird die an einem geheimen ort dem
schweizer hof zum ersten kurs aufgeboten
schon im aufgebot die erkennung die
erkennungszeichen abgemacht
das ist so dass man eine zeitung in der
rechten hand hat beim rodel punkt hatte
ich meinen koffer in der rechten hand
und wenn ich nicht mich nicht beobachtet
fühlte hatte ich unter den die und am
linken arm hatte ich eine zeitung ich
habe eine braune reisetasche habe eine
zeitung in der hand
damit er das signal demenz und so groß
braune haare und dann gab es noch das
sicherheitszeichen das
sicherheitszeichen war tabak pfeife im
mund die luft ist rein tabakpfeife in
der hand ist nicht gut er kann zu mir
hat mich angesprochen
sind sie der herr meyer von der
verzinkerei zug und da musste die
antwort sein die musste immer negativ
sein nein herrmanns krank ich vertrete
ihn und das wurde vor also die beiden
seit sie wurden vorher abgesprochen
wenn man sich geeinigt hat haben wir ein
paar schritte gemacht und dann stand ein
auto dorthin würden das privatauto
gestiegen
und dann sind wir an die dorfgrenze vom
staat gefahren anstatt in den ort hinein
sind wir außerhalb von start noch etwas
höher hinauf gefahren bewusst ja nicht
wo unser ausbildungszentrum wir wussten
wir es in dem start und werden sie
hochfahren zum schweizer hoch dann sehen
sie sie sehen das nicht dass sich
versteckt als es in der eigenen wohnung
in der wildnis
das auto stoppte an einer bestimmten
stelle und wir stiegen aus der fels vor
dem wir angehalten hatten sie überhaupt
nicht wie ein fels aus es war der
eingang des berühmten schweizer hofs
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der anteil gegen gang entlang das sind
lang und angeht da 45 meter hatte
seitdem gänge
in irgend einer tür die dann auf ging
waren 17 uhr für eine woche ich wurde
dann in ein einzelzimmer geführt und
dann im einzelzimmer war ein bett ein
tisch und ein monitor
april und das erste was wir taten war
den fernseher einzuschalten
lieber mitarbeiter lebe mitarbeiterin
aus gründen die sie sehr wohl verstehen
werden kann sich der generalstabschef
der schweizerischen armee nicht direkt
von auge zu auge am sie wenden wenn ein
generalstabschef reinen begrüßt und
seinem sagt warum bist sind sie hier
dann hat man schon auf lange hat man
eben schon frauen die organisation zu
der sie gehören kann nur funktionieren
wenn streckte geheimhaltungsvorschriften
zur anwendung kommen
das war für mich kein theater das
schafft vertrauen schafft auch eine
gewisse beruhigung gewissheit du machst
es nicht eine besetzung des landes darf
nicht das erlöschen jeden widerstandes
bedeuten ein gegner soll auch in diesem
fall nicht nur mit ablehnung sondern mit
aktiven widerstand rechnen müssen dachte
mein gott was für eine angelegenheit
habe ich mich da hinein gelassen der
sichtbare und der unsichtbare teil
unserer landesverteidigung sollen
mithelfen unserem land in schwieriger
zeit bessere chancen für das überleben
in freiheit und würde zu verschaffen
dann war mein gefühl dann schon wieder
etwas verflüchtigt und ich fühlte mich
eigentlich recht wohl
sie haben sich dann auch verpflichten
müssen verschwiegen zu sein und ihre
arbeit im stillen zu leisten
das team aber auf schloss wenn man aus
heute muss immer klingen dann hat man
die kapuze angezogen da wurde einem die
tür geöffnet und da kommt man zur
toilette oder um gegen das essen holen
oder magie zum rapport
aber sobald es kontakt mit licht und der
p 26 fällt mit blieben der p-26 hat man
die kapuze ersten zwei oder drei tage
habe ich sie immer getragen wenn ich
mein zimmer verließ
das war nur in den gängen und dann im es
sein wenn die anderen weg waren oder so
dann konnte man die wieder abziehen das
war gar nicht so schrecklich aber es ist
ein
es war einfach vorsichtsmaßnahmen die
ausnahme der masken regel schießübungen
mit den ausbildern gemacht mit pistolen
und zwar man muss sie lernen die pistole
zu laden und auch zu beginnen und dann
zu schießen
diese übungen waren eigentlich für den
selbstschutz waffen haben wir gar nicht
gehabt auch nicht mit nach hause
genommen oder irgendetwas das war alles
im bunker und da waren wir sehr gut
instruiert worden
[Musik]
im hotel schweizerhof hatten wir
maschinenpistolen und dort hatten wir
kurz einmal ein magazin geschlossen das
war um zu üben
die maschinenpistole funktioniert wie
kräftig reichen
das war um die selbstverteidigung etwas
rudimentär einzuüben also
die p 26 zählt bald 400 mitglieder
sie alle besuchen den schweizer hof sie
absolvieren kurse von vier oder mehr
tagen
drei bis viermal pro jahr um die
grundlagen des geheimen verhaltens zu
lernen
fünf jahre lang werden sie ausgebildet
jeder trainingstag wird mit einem sold
von 100 franken abgegolten
zur theorie kommen praktische übungen
hinzu beispielsweise wie man beschatter
abschüttelt
der trick ist langsam auf einer straße
zu spazieren wo es genug schaufenster
dudelt ich bin zum beispiel ein
liebhaber von uhren du schaust die uhren
in einer vitrine an lang genug um zu
sehen wer sich hinter dir bewegt und
dann gehst du zum nächsten schaufenstern
und beobachten ob sich zufällig derselbe
mann im fenster spiegel findest du raus
[Musik]
ich bin dann die straße bis zum ende
gegangen dort gibt es ein bistro
namensliste es befindet sich oberhalb
einer garage
das restaurant hat einen ausgang durch
diese garage und so habe ich meinen
verfolger abgehängt
die mich durch die garage entwickelt
diese idee ist er nicht gekommen
wahrscheinlich hatte mich nicht gesehen
dort war der austausch man trifft sich
und übergibt gegenseitig material das
ist der alte trick mit 21 austauschen
identischen man stellt sie ab sprich
seit paar worte über das weitere zu
schüttelt sich die hand und sieht man in
spionage filmen hat
[Musik]
geheimer lufttransport eine wichtige
operation um material zu erhalten das
für den widerstand nützliches
mussten wir mal mit pflücken das
bezeichnen oder mit tüchern tücher waren
auch noch eine lösung mit steinen
befestigt damit mir damit der pilot die
abbruchstelle sichtlich sehen konnte
dann müssen wir aber auch noch in die
windrichtung angeben für sowie die
ursachen haben wir gelernt zu machen
damit der pilot weiß wie er die sache zu
handhaben hat oben im flugzeug damit
dann dieses material an der richtigen
stelle
auf dem podium
[Musik]
material behälter werden an
verschiedenen orten des landes gelagert
bereit für den tag
darin findet man waffen darunter ein
gewehr das speziell für die sabotage
zwecke der p-26 entworfen wurde
ultra leise und präzis auf 100 meter
hätte dies triebe lichts wurde direkt an
die mitglieder verteilt
alles war in kleinen containern diesen
kleinen zylindern die den jeweiligen
aufträgen des mitglieds angepasst waren
derart also die übermittlung
regionalchef gerät ist die landeskarten
drin ist hat die sanitätsmaterial drin
operationsbesteck für notoperationen und
medikamente und zwei kantinen
goldplättchen wasserfilter feldstecher
sprengstoff sanitätsmaterial feld
feldstecher und für ein ganzes nutzen
und etwas gold war auch etwas
goldplättchen war auch der beifall ist
heute zu bestehen gibt nicole können sie
handeln mit gold wenn sie bezahlen und
das war das zahlungsmittel die die die
region braucht
april über das mitglied hatte absolut
nichts zu hause es musste nur ein
versteck für den moment vorbereitet an
dem diese zylinder an die mitglieder
verteilt werden aktiver doch irgendwo in
deinem garten auf einem dachboden oder
sonstwo musstest du ein sicheres
versteck vorbereiten probleme weil sie
dachte dann ziehen die nachbarn
plötzlich dass sich aktiv werden dem
garten die nachbarn haben mich nämlich
selten im garten aktiv gesehen und sagen
was denken sie wenn du jetzt im garten
anfängst zu graben und da kommt so ein
container daher hinter dem
verschlossenen tor des schweizer hofes
wird die b 26 heimlich aufgebaut ohne
dass es irgend jemand bemerkt 400
mitglieder alles freiwillige sind
bereits rekrutiert
sie werden in geheimen verhalten
sabotage der geheimen übermittlung von
dokumenten und tobago aktionen gesucht
doch am 26 februar 1990 enthüllt die
schweizer illustrierte das geheimnis ein
donnerschlag
manche mitglieder sind mitten in aktion
als sie davon erfahren
wir hatten übungen gemacht am morgen und
kann nicht sagen wann zwischen 10 12 und
recorder das geschäft das war ein schlag
in die magengrube
also es ist das kann man sich kaum
vorstellen wenn man sie vorsteht ali
vorbereitung und immer getroffen hat
waren hinein aus dem grunde nichts mehr
wert das heißt wir haben aufgeräumt dass
materialien freuen kombi bus vw-bus
getan ausgelagert das büro geräumt
es war nichts mehr schön zuruf das auf
die b 26 zurückzuführen also rückflüsse
hätte geben können
da haben wir uns verabschiedet und weg
waren hier das war eine schwierige zeit
vermischten sich natürlich auch sehr
viel fantasie finden
und und übertreibungen und nun war es
und das machte mir natürlich als
journalist große mühe weil ich ja das
blatt als stellt damals
stellvertretender chefredaktor der
bündner zeitung eigentlich mit zu
verantworten hatte sehr grosse mühe
also doch ein bürgerkrieg ähnliche
szenarien wurden da gezeichnet dann kann
die welt wochen verschiedene andere
eigentlich der grundtenor war immer eine
große hilfe um eine geheime die
anschuldigungen häufen sich aber die
mitglieder der p-26 sind an die
geheimhaltung gebunden sie müssen
schweigen
erstens mal konnte man darf es nicht
begreifen
und dann hat einem die aus den medien
diese die formierung auf geheime armee
und bewaffnet sind sie auch noch und was
haben die nicht alles war geld gekostet
alle diese vorwürfe dann vor allem die
illegalität tief zum großen vorwurf
gemacht worden ist dass das hat einem
wirklich wütend gemacht und und verrückt
man hat sich einfach still geärgert
es hat mich natürlich beschäftigt und
zwar aus zwei gründen auf der einen
seite ich wusste nicht wie geht es
weiter
muss sich überhaupt noch im kurs da in
ein paar wochen
zweitens das kann ja nicht weitergehen
schade für die organisation vom ersten
moment an
und drittens in dieser aufgeheizten
situation musste ich befürchten dass
mein name eines tages irgendwo
auftauchen würde
ich vorbeigehen chance wir dürfen eines
nicht vergessen ein jahr zuvor platzte
die bombe mit der 900.000 staatsschutz
vision
das war ein schock die leute fühlten
sich ein wenig vom staat betrogen
ein jahr später stolpern wir über eine
sogenannte geheime armee und wie
erfahren dass sie waffen haben und diese
ganze dämonisiere ich riet mir die augen
und fragte mich was da noch kommt der
schock hat seine wurzeln in die affäre
kommt bundesrätin elisabeth kopp muss
nach einem telefonat mit ihrem ehemann
zurücktreten
sie hatte ihn gewarnt seine firma sei in
den verdacht der geldwäscherei geraten
eine geheimnis verletzung
eine untersuchung folgt und so quasi
nebenbei wird entdeckt dass die
bundespolizei seit jahren mehr als
900.000 personen observiert angeblich
weil sie subversive aktivitäten
betrieben die kopp affäre wird zur
fischen affäre
[Musik]
mehr als 30.000 menschen protestieren
gegen die methoden des schnüffelt status
die entdeckung der p-26 wird zum funken
der die empörung explodieren lässt
nein
die atmosphäre war ziemlich überhitzt
und dann wurde die affäre präsentiert
als illegal kriminellen usw
es war sehr schwierig das zu hören aber
wir wussten sehr gut dass wir nichts
dagegen tun konnten dann enthüllt die
presse die identität des obersten chefs
der p-26 eher fremd catella code name
rico in einer pressekonferenz spricht
der fremdkapital zum ersten mal vor der
nation
dem habe ich mich mich mit überzeugung
gestellt wie wohl ich wissen musste dass
damit verbundenen in anführungszeichen
doppellebens los zeichen nicht psychisch
belasten würde
das heißt ich musste auch meinen eltern
nur meinen verwandten ich meine
berufliche tätigkeit verschweigen auch
belastend der lage recode hat er seine
wirkliche tätigkeit unter dem deckmantel
einer fiktiven beratungsfirma mit sitz
in basel für ein jahresgehalt von 180
tausend franken
dass man diskret aus dem von der armee
abzweigte in der öffentlichkeit wird zu
einer art staatsfeind
[Musik]
geld gm aber er war nicht gebildet und
überhaupt nicht gering ist überhaupt
kein verschwörer überhaupt nicht skurril
überhaupt kein rambo im gegenteil er war
ein ausgezeichneter chef ein
ausgezeichneter administrator und genau
das gegenteil all dieser klischees mann
sagte er sei der geheimnisvollste mann
des landes und schaut ihn an wie mit
einem fernglas ein tier in afrika und
dabei war ein ganz normaler aufrechter
offizier aber ein internes dokument der
p-26 alarmiert es erklärt unter welchen
umständen die organisation auch tätig
werden könnte
nämlich
[Musik]
innere politische umstürze durch
erpressung subversion und oder andere
vergleichbare aktivitäten einsatz der
zutiefst beunruhigt
das hat so extremen reaktionen geführt
weil es falsch verstanden wurde
wenn sie eine geheime organisation haben
die ein szenario über innere umstürze
auflistet ist die empörung riesig aber
es war ein großes missverständnis
rico dachte an fälle wie in der
tschechoslowakei im jahre 1948 als die
rote armee mit half beim putsch der
kleinen kommunistischen
minderheitspartei die party kommen ist
damit aber nie im leben dachte er
beispielsweise an einen großen wahlsieg
der linken alle behaupteten damals dass
die p-26 nach bern marschiert wäre wenn
die sozialdemokraten die wahlen gewonnen
hätten
das ist absolut abwegig und absurd ich
denke dieser punkt hätte niemals im
grundkonzept erscheinen dürfen
es wäre besser gewesen ihn nicht zu
erwähnen und ich weiß dass ricoh es
nicht eine ihrer aufgaben so hieß es
bestand darin innere feinde
auszuschalten
an wen hatten sie gedacht wir hatten uns
niemals gegen innere feinde vorbereitet
wir bereiten uns auf eine phase der
besetzung des landes vor ganz oder
teilweise durch einen feind von außen
zudem hatte sich inzwischen die welt
verändert das historische wahrzeichen
der ost-west-konfrontation die berliner
mauer fällt am 9 november 1989 vier
monate vor aufdeckung der b 26 einen
monat später wird das ende des kalten
krieges offiziell verkündet in malta auf
den gorbatschow bush gipfel
die nuklearen arsenale werden demontiert
die gründe mit denen die armee die
existenz der p-26 rechtfertigte sind weg
[Musik]
jetzt folgt enthüllung auf enthüllung im
nationalrat wird eine geheime gruppe von
fünf abgeordneten aufgedeckt die
armeechef hatte sie ohne wissen des
parlaments eingesetzt
das ziel eine art geheime aufsicht über
die geheimen aktivitäten der p-26 zur
gruppe gehörte der freisinnige
ich war in bern ein amtsdiener kommt und
sagt mir ein auto wartet vor dem
bundeshaus auf mich das auto bringt mich
nach belp in belp steige ich in einen
helikopter dieser fliegt mich nach start
dort steige ich in einen ski sie
verstehen das hatte einen hauch von
james bond ein tor im fels öffnet sich
ich trete ein und werde sehr herzlich
von einigen 50 jährigen begrüßt
sie erklärte mir wie es funktioniert
dass es schlafsäle gibt ich sehe ein
waffenlager und um ihr zu gefallen haben
sie mir sogar eine maschinenpistole in
die hände gedrückt und gesagt es gibt
übungen mit zielscheiben wollen sie es
versuchen
also versuche ich es und dann sagte
einer mit einem lächeln zu mir er
nationalrat
sie schießen wie eine gießkanne sie
waren ein erfahrener parlamentarier
hatten sie nicht den eindruck das ganze
sei eine alibiübung alibi ist zu viel
gesagt nochmals die tatsache dass diese
gruppe anonym ist schränkte den alibi
aspekt ein
ich würde lieber von einer art
risikoversicherung sprechen als von
einem alibi es war mehr eine
risikoversicherung das virus sich das
risiko ist wirklichkeit geworden
als all dies aufgedeckt wurde und
politische unruhen verursachte
marie vell worker der roma politik die
risikoversicherung hat nicht
funktioniert
das parlament setzte im märz 1990 eine
untersuchungskommission ein um die b26
zu durchleuchten
kaspar villiger der neue chef des
eidgenössischen militärdepartements
steht im mittelpunkt der kritik
abgesehen von der identität der nummer
eins weiß man zu diesem zeitpunkt nichts
über die anderen mitglieder der druck
steigt stetig dass die namen
veröffentlicht werden
am 12 dezember ruft mich der persönliche
assistent von herrn villiger an und sagt
herr villiger braucht die liste der
namen der p 26
wir haben den leuten zehn jahre lang
versprochen
ihre namen werden unsere büros nicht
verlassen
wir hatten einen safe mit einer doppel
kombination
ich besaß die eine hälfte ein kollege
die andere
die namen wurden wirklich streng
geschützt und dann wurde mir gesagt es
muss getan werden und zwar dringend
ich glaube ich erhielt den anruf am
abend und er brauchte die liste am
nächsten tag und ich habe es getan
ich hatte nicht erwartet herrn völliger
zu sehen ich erwartete die liste seine
mitarbeiter zu übergeben
aber dieser sagte mir ich fasse diese
liste nicht an
kommen sie mit ich verbrachte etwa eine
halbe stunde bei herrn villinger und
sagte ihm beiläufig ist für mich der
härteste tag der letzten 13 jahre sei
ein versprechen zu brechen dass man den
mitgliedern gegeben hat und seine
antwort kam postwendend er sagte mir
dass es der härteste tag seit ich im
bundesrat
als ich ihm die namen vorlegte schaute
er auf die liste
ich erinnere mich noch als ob es gestern
gewesen wäre
er musterte mich und sagte ich vertraue
ihm ich weiß dass viele bundesrat
villiger dafür kritisiert haben
26 zu decken oder nicht zu decken aber
sie müssen wissen dass er es war der
sich dafür entschieden hat die namen zu
schützen
er hätte es auch anders handhaben können
kaspar villiger entscheidet die namen
werden nicht bekannt gegeben
der politische und mediale druck steigt
weiter die behörden beschließen die
türen des schweizer hof für journalisten
zu öffnen
[Musik]
dezember 1990 der bericht der
untersuchungskommission wird
veröffentlicht er verursacht eine
marathon debatte im parlament
zwei tage lang wird diskutiert
die schweiz ist heute benebelt das
armeekader entmutigt das land
destabilisiert gute arbeit
wir richten uns an diejenigen die mit
patriotismus in diesen organisationen
gearbeitet haben um ihnen zu sagen dass
wir sie unterstützen
wir sind nicht damit einverstanden sie
läuten zum fraß vorzuwerfen die nicht
soviel patriotische gefühle haben wie
sie gibt es einen chef für
militärdepartement aber das ist sicher
nicht der bundesrat bei allem respekt
für die demokratischen institutionen
ich glaube wenn ich sehe wie der chef
des militärdepartements von seinen
mitarbeitern übers ohr gehauen wird
das villinger auf der regierungsbank und
ich sagte zu ihm herr bundesrat wir
bezeichnen das als einen skandal weil
die p 26 vielleicht auf einer etwas
klareren rechtsgrundlage hätte beruhen
müssen vielleicht hätten sie als
verteidigungsminister besser auf dem
laufenden sein
vielleicht war das auch zu leichtfertige
weise organisiert was die rechtliche
absicherung betrifft weil vielleicht an
dem punkt wo wir am ende des kalten
krieges standen die rechtmäßigkeit und
sogar die rechtfertigung hätten
diskutiert werden können die räte aber
schließlich sind diejenigen die jetzt
beschuldigt werden die sie beschuldigen
lassen
das sind leute die sich einsetzten die
bereit waren unsere heimat unser
territorium unsere demokratie unsere
werte zu verteidigen
bis zur opferung ihres lebens also mehr
als andere
sie waren mehr als nur einfache
staatsbürger
der untersuchungsausschuss anerkennt das
tt 26 mitglieder keine zitat
staatsgefährdenden absichten hatten
fällt da war ein strenges gesamturteil
eine geheime mit waffen und sprengstoff
ausgerüstete organisation stellt an sich
eine potenzielle gefahr für die
verfassungsmäßige ordnung wenn sie von
den verfassungsmäßigen politischen
behörden nicht auch faktisch beherrscht
wird
diese leute so wie sie waren waren alles
andere als faschisten
sie waren keine potenziellen chiaty
sie waren gute demokratische
republikaner die einfach so dachten seit
dem motto republica demokrat chiesa
blaser cola
auch wenn der bericht diesen
menschlichen aspekt außer acht lässt
der für mich entscheidend ist ob wir
attraktiv struktur hätte mehr politische
absicherungen verlangt
dazu sage ich ja
die politik b26 und gleich lautet die
schlagzeile just zu dieser zeit gleich
oder claudio so nennt sich die
italienische stay behind organisation
und gleich gerät in einen schrecklichen
verdacht
sie soll mit rechtsextremen gemeinsame
sache machen
im august 1980 explodierte am bahnhof
bologna eine bombe 85 menschen sterben
die geheime claudio soll mitgewirkt
haben
hatte die p-26 beziehungen zur gladio
oder anderen ähnlichen ausländischen
organisationen kaspar villiger will es
wissen
er beauftragt den untersuchungsrichter
von neuenburg pierre cornu zu ermitteln
maria gute laune besserte mir hören sie
letztes jahr sind bei der
untersuchungskommission dinge raus
gekommen die ich nicht wusste man hatte
mir nicht alles erzählt ich wusste nicht
wer von der p-26 ausland kontakte hat
ich bin es leid gewisse dinge aus den
zeitungen zu erfahren was gehört ich
will nicht dass es in sechs monaten
nochmals jemanden gibt der mich etwas
vorlegt als beweis dass ich nicht alles
wusste um die songs haben die
grundlegende frage war wie waren die
beziehungen zwischen 26 und dem ausland
waren es ähnliche organisationen waren
es geheimdienste war es die nato waren
sie individuen wenn ja welche wie warum
und mit welchen methoden alle leute die
für die eidgenossenschaft arbeiten vom
einfachen beamten bis zum armeechef war
mir gegenüber völlig entbunden von ihrer
militärischen geheimhaltungspflicht
niemand konnte mir also sagen nein ich
antworte nicht weil alles geheim ist
heim war streng geheim keine stufen der
geheimhaltung konnten mich aufhalten
lockere kontakte zu großbritannien
zwecks ausbildung
aber sonst nichts eine ermittlungen
haben absolut keine hinweise ergeben
wonach die b 26 kontakt zu anderen
ausländischen diensten gehabt hätte ja
ich kann ihnen sagen dass ich geforscht
habe ich ihn nach belgien wo es auch
eine parlamentarische
untersuchungskommission gab die sehr gut
ausgestattet waren also nahm ich ging
nach italien wo es einen richter namens
kassen gaben die ermittler war die am
meisten an diesen fragen von gladio
gearbeitet hatte und der geheimen stay
behind organisationen
auch wenn ich das meine erste frage war
immer ab 8 uhr haben sie das wort
schweiz
es gehört ja gibt es den schatten einer
spur
dass die schweizer an einer sitzung
teilgenommen es gibt es den schatten
einer spürt dass eine sitzung in der
schweiz organisiert worden wäre
gab es gemeinsame übungen wussten diese
europäischen organisationen davon was in
der schweiz passiert die antwort war
eindeutig nein ich habe mein bericht
persönlich nach bern gebracht denn da
sind ziemlich geheim
das ist nicht etwas was man mit der post
verschickt
also habe ich mein bericht nach bayern
gebracht wo er studiert anschließend
hatte ich eine unterredung mit
anfälliger der sehr erfreut war wirklich
war zufrieden als er sagte das ist ja
großartig was sie in diesen paar monaten
alles in erfahrung gebracht haben
und dann fragt er mich sind noch mehr
leichen im keller glauben sie nun
endlich alles zu wissen da habe ich
geantwortet
auf jeden fall habe ich alles getan was
ich konnte kann alles zu erfahren
es gibt dinge die wir wahrscheinlich nie
wissen werden aber ich glaube nicht dass
es wichtig ist und ich denke nicht dass
sich die schlussfolgerungen endet heute
nach ist sein bericht unter verschluss
und vor wenigen wochen meldete die
parlamentarische
geschäftsprüfungsdelegation die beilagen
des berichts die befragungs protokolle
seien verschwunden sie sind nie im
bundesarchiv aufgetaucht dazu der
historiker titus meier
der bericht zwischen hier integral der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht wurde
es ist ein bericht probleme für den
bundesrat enthalten informationen wo
wieder ganz aus der auswahl bis jetzt
weiß und wie das kommt seines
umstrittenes thema ist wenn man
natürlich weiß er was hätte herr korn
user von des inneren untersuchung aller
phasen publiziert was er publiziert und
das kann nur ein original bricht und
original lockte und ausgang minute
verursacht bis hoch bis am cent haltet
also dass man sich nicht wie sie es bis
ans enthalten will
dann hätte der brecht verschwinden aber
der bericht ist vorhaben der nächsten
planvorhaben der politischen brisanz
erwarte aber natürlich die historiker
interessantes dokument war völlig zu
anderen fragen wird eine antwort geben
linke politiker fordern vollständige
einsicht in den bericht
jene die damals dabei waren stehen immer
noch voll hinter der p-26 oder ich hatte
keine zweifel je in dieser organisation
mitzumachen
ich finde auch es ist wichtig nur schon
dass es einmal so objektive möglich
festgehalten werden kann
es gab zeiten nach 2009
da machen die meisten großen bogen um
die medien herum
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht hatten
es ist ein stück geschichte
[Musik]
china präsentiert wurde woanders